it's the latest fine for a troubled bank
yes and before all the charges were
preliminary investigations friends
Authority is now opening a formal
investigation into the london-based bank
here essentially this 1 billion dollars
means that the bank is guaranteed to be
represented should the case go to trial
and should and if they would have to pay
any fines and damages some would argue
this 1 billion dollars does it really
mean anything to a bank as big as HSBC
probably not but the bigger implication
here is that French authority is really
trying to punish these banks that have
been accused of tax evasion for their
clients they're not gonna let this issue
wash by them anymore but again this all
comes just five months after HSBC was
already fine 53 million dollars by
French authorities uh with a bail bond
there and three months after the same
unit drew some fresh scrutiny from UK
lawmakers there you may remember when
Stuart Gulliver Douglas Flint to the CEO
and chairman of HSBC being grilled by
lawmakers there Gulliver perhaps he
could even more of a grilling because of
his own personal former personal Swiss
account that he had registered under a
company in Panama it's but with all
these big bangs so there is this
expectation that more fines could be
coming when we look down the line here
in fact Deutsche Bank said they're close
to reaching a settlement on this 1.5
billion dollar deal on liber there this
is a probe by US and UK authorities
there on those interest rate
manipulations okay Gulliver saying that
that Panamanian account was because of
privacy he actually did pay the taxes on
his bonus and all of this stuff but how
is this all part of a radical
transformation that HSBC says they've
been going through since 2007 mean is
this the latest i guess weakness on that
transformation journey yeah in fact it's
another hurdle i think because when you
look at it they say we've apologized
we've strengthened their task appliances
since 2007 when these allegations
surfaced chair but when it comes to
these recent finds here HSBC seems to be
doing another 180 on their tone there
they're saying look this bail bond is
too
has no legal basis the bail is
unwarranted and excessive they say and
they will appeal and quote defend itself
as vigorously as possible